I think it goes in along the lines of
what you were talking about and I think
that really struck part with me is just
kind of like
just waited out dude it's gonna be fine
like you know the issues that you think
that you come up with in your head and I
think all the issues that I found out
[Music]
so we
we are back on this amazing episode of
be careful boys right here but we're
currently off the Record and we're doing
part two of an OTR prompt of a
two-parter I told you it was two-parter
you're right right uh we got through
being able to talk about Steve Ryan and
Bart but now we're gonna go into the
other half the cast and this OTR prompt
was submitted by a Jenny dang so thank
you hey it's a good one Jenny very good
very good question got us all thinking
from the patreon by the way yep and if
you're a part of our Discord because
you're a special patreon member you can
ask us questions
so think about your most difficult time
during your teenage years
and then what advice would you give that
Team part two starting off with Nick
I just uh skip
nah skip didn't have problems when I was
a team no I was proud
can you make one I didn't want the
attention I'm an introvert it was too
early for me I can't believe they forced
me in that situation one problem that I
had that was like really hard for me was
like just having too many friends to
pick from I'm just kidding I'm joking
like so when you graduate high school
two years yeah too many girlfriends too
many friends and she was crushing it too
hard no no he was prom King couldn't
handle this one was tough because I was
really trying to figure out like what
really stuck out of my head that was um
I think it was very unconscious for a
lot of my time like a lot of my teenage
years but I think there was always a
sense of never really belonging to
something or like just not having like
really good friends to be around like I
was always kind of
I think I felt some type of way about it
for a while I think from like my middle
school to high school I just was really
worried about making sure
I was really worried about people liking
me
and I really wanted to make sure that
like okay I had like a good group of
friends kind of it's kind of hard to
explain but it was one of those things
where I just never felt like I belonged
to any group of friends and I never had
like a really true good friend if that
makes sense is it because you were
leaving early in I would just bail out
the report yeah yeah did you ever have
like a best friend growing up
like guys that I would people that I
thought were best friends that would
like do things that I was like
they would kind of be like mean or like
kind of like backstab me or do something
in a way in my mind at the time like I
don't know if it was really backstabby
or not but I perceived it as like
damn I thought this guy was my friend
type of deal you know so maybe I'm just
a piece of [__] maybe I'm just the
scumbag you didn't have like a click or
anything that you hung out with not
really like I would have like a lot of
different groups of friends but I'd
always feel like maybe this is a
reflection of what I do today bro I
would keep them at like arm's distance
kind of or or not even just that I think
I did that later in my high school years
but um yeah it's I'm actually kind of
thinking I'm trying to like think this
out as I'm talking to you guys but um
let us in man but I'm trying I'm trying
I'm trying someone tell me it's not my
fault they'll start crying it's not your
fault did you ever
um ask me more questions like I really
don't know like your best friend that
you thought was shady back then do you
think they're still Shady now no I think
which is my perception of what like my
expectations and I think this is also
true like the first girl I was like
uh interested I think my expectations
were so different than what reality oh
yeah yeah I remember you said it was
like weird so I think um that was kind
of hard for me but it was just lessons
that I learned really quick where I just
was like oh okay maybe it's just not
what I thought it was gonna be you know
so what did you think it was going to be
like based off of movies or something
kind of like I think I was kind of
raised off movies
like like because growing up I think I
did with no sound effects yeah yeah I
did spend a lot of my time by myself
so I think like in my household like it
was like my sisters would be with each
other or whatever and my mom would you
know you'd just be watching speed yeah
honestly like I would just like I would
live through movies I would live through
TV shows I would think that's what real
life was so I think I went throughout my
whole life thinking and I would always
be kind of chasing that in a lot of ways
that gives you high expectations for
sure yeah definitely and I think like
the reality was never as cool as true
what I I dealt with and I think did you
want you're like your own like three
ninjas type crew like like is that what
you're looking for like a that would be
tight yeah because Goonies I always
wanted that Goonies are always better
like a Brotherhood Circle Dude I think
maybe that's what it was I think a
certain degree well I was looking for
something like that I remember as a kid
I'd always read like Calvin and Hobbs
all the time yeah I love cows yeah and I
had all of them yeah and I would just
like I would should have joined the gang
bro I know that's the perfect place but
in a lot of ways I think I didn't really
feel that until I started until like
found a gym in that camaraderie like
that's what I really liked I think being
around that environment taught me a lot
more that's cool
um but as far as advice I give it to
myself I think it goes in along the
lines of what you were talking about and
I think that really struck part with me
it was just kind of like
just [__] wait it out dude it's gonna
be fine like you know the issues that
you think that you come up with in your
head and I think all the issues that I
found out
I said like
pursue what feels more natural you're
gonna don't hide that card I literally
[Laughter]
all these kids the guys that
skateboarded yeah
I distance myself from those guys that I
was immediately cool with on day one
because we're not judgmental yeah to the
Asian kids that did crime I felt like I
had to prove to them when I should have
just been like oh yeah all my skate
buddies I should just be more of my
skating instead of being with the group
he wanted to he wanted validation from
the wrong group yeah I don't think
that's what you said
do you think that when we're when we're
all talking Nick's just thinking I can't
wait to get the [__] out he's all
checked out and [__] I got my go back so
if you could talk to yourself in that
period rather than like telling the
youth from then how to feel differently
about it is there anything you could
tell that person to do differently like
it was being advice on like yeah it's
things to do with places to go how to
make friends
like if you want friends so bad if you
want that Circle so bad because a lot of
people feel that now I think more than
ever there's so many more lonely just
people that especially like coveted kids
and [__] like they don't know how to
make friends they're socially weird I
think like um
yeah they smell bad they have dandruff
how else can we roast our audience they
have walleyes we can't quite get away
from their eyes
I have walleyes would you would you tell
yourself to join uh fight gym like
sooner
man
what would you tell that lonely ass boy
no I because I think in my mind I
thought I was I wasn't lonely you know
what I mean so if you talk to that guy
he'd go what are you talking about man
yeah he'll deflect you he'll deflect
your future he would deflect yourself I
think the lesson is just managing your
expectations you know what I mean like
the future nickels look Little Nick
check this out I know you want friends
no I don't he's like
nope but I think that's true though I
think yeah a kid version of me or just
like early 20s version of me too like in
my head I thought I had it all figured
out
[Laughter]
yeah yeah wonderful wearing a fanny pack
yeah like that guy that's gonna be me
just [__] walks into traffic
or your younger years like why is that
guy on YouTube do you think you were so
stubborn you wouldn't even listening
he's like he's like dude you're not
older me it's like I hate cyclists oh
[__] that's me I think for me I think I
had to learn the hard way in a lot of
things I think I really did all right
let's say like it's your son same age
same problem now you have the same
yeah you're a stubborn little [__] and I
know exactly what you're going through
because I was going through that but you
still have to let them know what the
remedy is for loneliness here we go
Uncle Bart says wait it out
oh man I dropped that one huh
oh man that's that's a tough question
this product is hard
stuff I haven't been processed I think
there's props and like there's bullets
under it which are Nick prompts you have
to like arrange it down the line Nick
it's special question yeah your son is
lonely yeah and your son's not a pug
Nick gets special friends you know what
you know you know what Nick's problem is
he [__] wants a perfect answer just
shoot your goddamn shot and it could be
wrong
yeah all right right no because I'm
really trying to think like if I was
really gonna try to help this person in
this situation
man I don't know if I'm well equipped
enough to say it but I will
say something
it's you I would say manager
expectations that's what I would
honestly say you'd probably yell at
yourself you'd be like yo you don't have
[__] figured out you think you guys
should figure it out that means no hope
manage your expectations means hey
Leonard you have all these locked
expectations let's go down like like if
like if your son was literally like I
don't have a dedicated group of friends
I feel kind of lonely I don't got like a
true homie and Nick's like sucks to be
you dog maybe you should be used to
being lonely instead of wanting friends
my boy damn that's I think I might say
that that's bad advice no no but I would
say um just start with one friend
you know because a lot of people miss
the baby step that's that's like I just
want my Goonies crew yeah yeah yeah it's
like how are you gonna make three ninjas
if you can't even make two Ninjas
that's true you guys start with one yeah
you're the first Ninja first you have to
want to be the ninja yeah I want the
Phoenix to get this is hard it is
because you think you think words that
an adult would process but kids just
want to hear references and I'll get
frustrated be like I don't know that's
that's my move yeah honestly so what
about you Anthony yeah what about you
Anthony what would you tell your dry
cleaner ass kid I have um so I'm sad ass
dry cleaner boy spoken on this before so
I'll say this one it's very similar to
Barts um where waited out wait it out
no it's it's be it's just be way more in
tune with your natural self right uh uh
I definitely knew that I like liked
dancing and I wanted to or if I saw
people dancing as a as a pre-teen as a
teenager but I didn't start dancing till
college but again and this is such a
a dumb time because there was one dude
who was on the dance production team at
my high school at Sunny Hills and he was
like pretty for sure gay or at least
that's what like you know the school
kind of status quo assumed he's like for
show gay yeah so everyone had a
stereotype that all dancers were gay
because of this guy
sexual orientation okay my ignorance my
ignorance was like Yo dude like I don't
want to dance because I don't want to
you know like give myself that social
suicide that's just how the times were
oh no no yeah
I don't think anyone looked at a
breakdown sir and called him gay that's
what I'm saying I just didn't connect
the mature thought
yeah yeah I was waiting for you dude for
your [__] self out I could picture
Stephen high school and there's a break
dancer doing a head spin and he's like
once you suck a dick it's easier might
as well such a dick you spinner boy
and uh yeah so there's that honest thing
yeah I like that but um I've spoken on
that one before I think
um that and just to just to give
something else just to be vulnerable in
this conversation and to add something
else I I was thinking about something
else uh I remember when I first uh
somebody broke up with me and I thought
it was the end of world right I was like
one of my first girlfriends
um I was so into her oh my gosh and even
though we only dated for like a month or
two and then she breaks up with me and I
remember just like trying to listen to
all the sad songs being depressed and so
like I think my world
and then uh I think coupled with just
feeling like a loser in that moment and
then also being like you know how I like
always joke around about being like if I
saw my high school so I slap him yeah
yeah oh me too yeah that guy's honestly
a [__] dick he was a loser is an
idiot right um like I that that kid I'm
speaking in third person so I don't have
to acknowledge it was me uh that guy
didn't you know try it out for different
like sports teams athletic stuff didn't
make any of them got dumped by this girl
right and so what I slash he did pretty
bad
[__] it up no you're not I am and it
still hurts you you caught him a loser
dude I did call him you did call him a
loser yeah um but Bart said wait it out
but there's one thing that I think I've
never I never really thought about this
too until I had to process it I think
there's one thing that I maybe didn't at
time
maybe it was a coping mechanism but I
also think uh if I think about it now
I'm a little ashamed of
um I maybe felt so much of a loser in a
certain way that I felt in order to make
myself feel better I had to
uh especially in the in the women's
scene and like the dating and stuff like
that I started
flirting with like
kind of the less desirable girls in like
my class and stuff because I felt like
that might be the only space that maybe
they would give me a certain type of
attention and so inadvertently these
like less attractive and lesser cooler
nerdy or whatever girls that would
normally not be a top three pick in any
conversation ever and you dunk all of
them a little harder
with you can you rip their heads off a
little bit
[Laughter]
them on and played with their feelings I
didn't know that's what I was doing sure
about that sure about that sure about
that
dude Anthony's going over to the mutant
section
for an ego boost hey but I remember
I had a I had a group of girl girl
friends or like like female friends that
would go to the club for ego boost for
the same reason
they're not gonna date any of these guys
they know they're like yeah not guys but
they want to feel yeah they want to feel
the attention you did the same thing
you're a club girl that's that's feeding
off with the attention that you know you
want to it's like when a boxer loses a
big fight right yeah they gotta get back
to the ring they need a tune-up gotta
hit some scrubs yeah yeah I didn't know
I was doing that until like later on
yeah
like later on my cousin who went to the
same high school as me and he'd be like
yo like why does this person like like
you or whatever I'm like nah dude like
what are you talking about and I'll just
go around because word will get around
because you're a little flirt dude you
are a little flirt well that's how I
maybe that's how I needed to learn it
for myself as well yeah because in my
mind or in my in my world my universe uh
I was getting dumped on right like I was
a loser in these girls these girls
weren't super into me so I felt like I
needed to go to a different you got to
read the game you need to reset the
hierarchy somewhere yeah that makes
sense but then I probably inadvertently
was like leading certain people on and
stuff and like doing it probably a very
asshole-ish way you know like hey man
she hopes really into you and like
you're like you're leading her on a lot
but again why are you flirting with job
with a baby she-hulk's kind of hot
though I think the constructive Point uh
to the first thing just like Bart said
with the whole dance thing it's like you
you just be be in tune with what you
want to do like I think the world is
made for the takers not for the waiters
you know what I'm saying that's very
true for show gay guys
you have told your younger self to just
join dance if that's what you want
that's what I mean it's like if that's
what you like just do it yeah like who
gives a [__] you know what I mean like
and if it's like no but like what if
people think I'm gay or whatever because
that was just a real thought back then
then that would have to lead into a more
mature concept of like not worrying
about would you tell your young self hey
being gay is pretty cool the future
that is literally the future though the
most popular kids are I probably just
I'm probably just trying to correct that
idiot mind sooner in just those same
words those same words
would you tell a kid today like hey dude
don't be slumming it with those fives
you want to be like aim higher like
automatically what are you doing I know
you know what the thing is though like I
was probably a four at that time sure
you know what I'm saying so I don't know
maybe it's very hard to say maybe they
were doing that to you yeah maybe they
were doing it too yeah yeah but would
you like actually go to a school for
example and just go like hey get out of
the [__] box
in a speech don't be like me you know
treat yourself like you're a new release
what was your method of flirting at that
young of an age you know what the thing
is though like when you're going to The
Bargain Bin oh my Lord that's what he
said I'm just using his words so I could
be relative to the conversation for
example it's like with nixes for example
that's not what I'm saying it
sounds so mean I think that like um like
you're bent over that Marketplace and
you're just like you're going to the Box
going all the way in there
I would assume I would assume that like
me at that time I wasn't getting [__]
like hit on by like hot chicks or
anything like that just as much as
because I was probably a loser ass dude
just as much as like maybe
the same level if you will type of like
ladies maybe weren't getting the
attention from other dudes so it felt
like okay this is like free-for-all safe
space I could just go in you know what I
mean because it's like they're not
getting the the love and attention from
anybody it's like and that's what high
school is about too right it's like oh
who asked you to the dance like people
ain't asking these people to dance
it's as objective as that so you're just
asking them to the dance kind of but not
really don't you dance like this
that's when everybody starts lying about
boyfriends or girlfriends they have from
another town oh yeah that's a good movie
yeah
yourself like
um like he had to learn his lessons just
like Nick said right you just have to do
stuff yeah and it's not intentional just
wait it out
just wait it out you'll be okay
just try to get better at stuff that's
it just try to do trying to do something
that's different than waiting yes you're
doing something yeah yeah that's true
versus just oh that's a pass I'm not
gonna do anything yeah yeah I'm gonna
take a nap try to do better you wasted
20 years of your life just doing nothing
it's funny because Bart's saying waited
out is such a non-bark thing to do like
he would never say that this will pass
it's such not a bar thing
um
it's such a it's such a like he just
filled in multiple choice answers
that's a filling answer baby
theme to Nick it's like hey just start
with one friend yeah yeah honestly yeah
yeah one friend yeah well we go through
so yours just start with the ones yeah
oh no it doesn't get worse than that
next you'll get to two you start with
the most ugliest person in there just
keep trucking along dude just keep
tracking and he's like find the nuclear
power plant in your city and start
dating around it start dating around it
go to Chernobyl start moving away yeah
don't go for Princess Leia look for
Jabba the Hutt and then give them
attention get your reps in look forward
you look for a job on the hood
practice with them [__] it's a joke but
honestly it's true though it's kind of
tricky
oh yeah you opened up Anthony Lisa start
with the uggos first
Auntie Lee says go to batting practice
Anthony Lee said it we didn't say it
Steve said Bargain Bin dude and then
nuclear powerful and he showed himself
digging to the bottom of it
that's the worst part and that's his
story dude that's his [__] up story
you think we're bad people yeah don't go
don't go to the cheerleaders go to the
lunch ladies go to the lunch lady hey
honestly got a good advice though dude
please don't say you said learn to be
Charming with the Lunch Ladies
[Music]
foreign